what I set out in my book fairness for
all which comes out today is that our
productivity in the UK is below the g7
average by quite a bit and what I think
is that if workers are more involved if
employees are more involved in the
success of their company then we can
improve productivity and what I talk
about is the importance of sharing
information more freely making sure that
people are empowered to shape their
future and to improve processes and
service at work but then also crucially
to make sure that some of the value
that's then created is passed back so
those that are creating the value is
that easier to do in a business like the
John Lewis Partnership than it is in a
PLC way or on support or outside
shareholders I think no if again you
look at all the evidence what it says is
that earnings per share are a hundred
and forty three percent higher in
businesses that have highly engaged
workforces so the question to ask is
what you have to do to have a highly
engaged workforce now the the chap who
set up the John Lewis Partnership
speedin Lewis was well ahead of his time
what he thought is if I look after my
people really well and they're happy and
they're engaged they're going to be more
involved in the company's success
they're going to be happier they're
going to work harder and my customers
are going to get better service and if
my customers get better service then
we're going to be more profitable and
sustainable over the long course
so what speeding lewis did about a
hundred years ago was to recognize that
there was a way of being more
sustainable and more profitable which
meant that you focused on your people
first and the shareholders ultimately
got the advantage rather than thinking
about your shareholders first and your
people last of all but if I'm a CEO how
do I do that I mean that's not something
that can be turned around overnight no
you're right I mean people have to think
very differently about their approach so
what I've set up today as well as
publishing the book is a website called
measuring workplace happiness calm it's
free anybody can go and use it and what
that will do is measure your happiness
at work it will compare it to others and
my hope is that through that people will
start having an engagement with their
line managers they'll talk amongst
themselves about what we can do to make
this a happy and a more engaging place
to work and then as a consequence of
that the business will grow productivity
will be higher
sales will be higher profits will be
higher I give lots of examples where
shrinkage is less defects are fewer
there are fewer health and safety
incidents staff turnover is lower so
there are now lots of measured benefits
all done through academic research on
why and engage workforce is going to
deliver better results for any company
or any organization public services any
organization but can that work when a
business or a particular sector is in
crisis where they're fighting for their
lives where they're losing market share
to competitors where their business
model may be being flattened by the
online advance the are march of the
internet and so on
in my view even more so so in times of
great change that we're going through
now as we enter this digital era it's
very important that employees understand
what's going to happen going forward and
with that information they're then
impaired to help shape the future and
then they take a share of the benefits
in the future it's far better to do that
so that people understand the background
to the circumstances that they're living
in and working in that they don't that
they feel things are being done unto
them so what I try to explain in the
book is that by sharing information
being more open being more transparent
then allowing people to start shaping
the future that you want has a real
benefit but not only for the company for
society as well I think we'll have a
more engaged society if we have people
involved in their work and shaping the
way that they live